yes sorry so for the next few minutes
I'm going to talk about literally
nothing I'm going to talk about the
vacuum void nothingness and and how
scientists really really need a vacuum
need something that's empty of molecules
to do a lot of experiments it's very
very important for the work we do where
we want to manipulate individual atoms
and molecules you want to keep it in a
vacuum and make sure that you get as few
molecules sort of contaminant molecules
interacting or bonding to the surface as
you can however you can never ever reach
our perfect vacuum and that's related
fundamentally again to quantum mechanics
the unit we use for pressure well we use
a range of Units we actually one of the
the interesting ones is tor which stems
from Torricelli's and Torricelli's was
one of the first people to build it was
was the first person to build a
barometer and 760 Torr is the
atmospheric pressure and that stems from
to a certain extent stems from the
height of a column of mercury that
atmospheric pressure can actually
sustain the other unit we use is the
Millie bar which is perhaps more
familiar but the unit that the SI unit
the proper SI unit misses in terms of
Newton's per meter squared is the Pascal
and so atmospheric pressure is 10 to the
5 a hundred thousand very roughly ten to
the five Pascal but when I just roll
that number that 100,000 Pascal like
that that's just a number it doesn't
really make it mean a lot but if we
think about what that actually means in
terms of force and the force on an area
it's a huge force 100,000 Newtons per
meter squared is equivalent to about a
ton of force on on an area which is
about a foot square a huge huge amount
of force just raining down on us and we
forget just I guess we're just so used
to living with that we forget how much
force that that can actually impart
so the the vacuum in a vacuum cleaner
compared to the experiments we do is it
just terrible useless nonsense we
couldn't do anything without type of
vacuum turns out that the vacuum and
vacuum cleaner if we start off with
atmospheric pressure of about a hundred
thousand Pascal the vacuum in a vacuum
cleaner is roughly something like 70 or
80 thousand Pascal's so not a very very
big change the key thing there is though
what's happening is that sometimes we
get this idea that when we use a vacuum
cleaner that's something is sort of
actively sucking the more important
thing is that what you've got is air
pressure that is it's the force of the
after of the air streaming into a region
where there is no where or the amount of
air has been reduced that actually gives
you that force that allows you to to
clean things dust isn't sucked into a
vacuum cleaner it's pushed in it's
effectively pushed in yeah it's in trend
but there's something called viscous
flow so it gets entrained with the air
and it's basically pushing into it's
driven along with the air so this idea
of sucking is is actually not quite
what's happening on see a pretty vivid
demonstration of that later on we really
want to work at not a hundred thousand
Pascal or eighty thousand Pascal we are
actually wanna go down and work at nano
Pascal pressures so 10 to the minus nine
of a Pascal and that the pressure we
work with in the lab in our routine
experiments is comparable to that you
actually get in the surface of the moon
so we want to remove all those molecules
I can get down to those type of
pressures right so what we have here is
a tube which I'm about to evacuate we
talked earlier but just how much force
air an air pressure can impart hopefully
we're going to see quite a dramatic
illustration of that so what I'm gonna
do is going to pump the air out of this
pipe with a rotary pump vacuum pump in
here there's a ping-pong ball I don't
I've got a very simple scene here in a
very simple seal here the seal on this
end is just the end of a plastic cup we
put that on there that's going to be
held in place busy by the air pressure
will be a vacuum it will be the air
pressure oldness on this side I've just
taped it up with some tip I'm a pump it
out I'm going to leave it for a few
seconds and then I'm going to put this
family knife rupture the seal at the
back here the air will rush in and the
ping-pong ball will go flying at the end
if we do this right the ping-pong ball
should fly out at about 400 miles and
or something like that hopefully we
pulverize the coke can right let's try
yes sorry good so let's see what it did
but certainly pulverize the coca and in
fact with a longer length and a bit more
oomph or you're going to go straight
through the the coke can
you should take from that the the rather
large forces that air alone can actually
impart that as I said the ball it's a
ping-pong board where is it I don't know
it didn't go in the bin did it oh that's
fantastic
actually in this case it hasn't been
that the ping pong ball hasn't been
damaged well that's a standard ping pong
tennis ball tennis table tennis ball 40
millimeters diameter very very very like
weird and it ended up in a pin and it
pulverized a Coker so that's the force
that air pressure alone can actually
exert a really nice way of looking at
vacuums are getting getting a good
insight into what a vacuum is is to look
at something called the mean free path
how far can a particle get before on
average before it smacks into another
particle and in the atmospheric pressure
turns out to be a very very very small
distance it's about a hundred nanometers
so on average and an air molecule in the
air can only travel about a hundred
nanometers a hundred billions of a meter
before it smacks into another one when
we get down to really really low
pressures like ten to the minus nine and
nano Pascal which is what we work with
in the lab or pressure on the moon then
what we have is a mean free path that is
many thousands of kilometers so those
those molecules have a very very lonely
journey true true through the void
before they actually bounce into another
molecule it's amazing from one
perspective and that we can get down to
those pressures but the amount of pins
sometimes that's involved in trying to
get get or experimental equipment to get
down to those pressures can be can be
quite tricky for example one of the
things we have to do with our stainless
steel vacuum chambers to get down to
those pressures regardless of sort of
the quality of the pomping we use is we
have to bake them we literally put them
in an oven and cover them or loop tin
foil make them nice and toasty and bring
the temperature up to about 150 degrees
and the reason we have to do that is
because if we don't do that all the
water that's in it that covers all these
surfaces in air there's a thin water
film just sits there and over courser
time just gradually those water
molecules come out and pollute or vacuum
because you have to get rid of all those
molecules okay let's have another go
better vacuum buildup and now let's try
yeah yes that was good oh it's shattered
a bit of it we're getting close to it
maybe if we keep improving if we go to a
second generation version you might
actually punch right through
you